All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, today, let's go over
some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself
during the talk and please use
chatroom to post your questions
so that you can address them in
the q&a session at the end. A
second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audiences.
Therefore, no classified
discussion is allowed. So please
watch out. Finally the talk
today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Let me
introduce our speaker today. It
is an honor to host Thomas
Becker's who is an assistant
professor of computer science
and the Institute for soft
software integrated systems at
Vanderbilt University. Before
joining Vanderbilt, he was a
postdoctoral researcher at the
Department of Electrical and
Systems Engineering University
of Pennsylvania, where he was
the member of the Grasp lab and
precise and offset Center. In
2020, he earned his doctorate in
electrical engineering at the
Technical University of Munich,
Germany. He received a BSc and
MSc degree in electrical
engineering in 2010 and 2013,
respectively, from the Technical
University of Braunschweig. Also
in Germany, in 2018, he was a
visiting researcher at the
University of California
Berkeley, very close from here,
and he is a DAAD AInet fellow
and was awarded with a Rohde
Schwarz Outstanding Dissertation
price. His research interests
include physics, enhanced
learning, nonparametric, models
and safe learning based control.
Today, Thomas will present an
exciting topic, which is physics
enhanced Gaussian process for
learning of electromagnetic
electromechanical systems.
Please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk. Now without
further ado, let me pass the
baton to Thomas by asking one
random question. Today's random
question is, what is your idea
of the perfect
All right, first of all, thank
you very much for the kind
introduction. And yeah, so my
perfect day, since you said I'm
coming from Germany, like from
Munich, so a Munich is very
close to Europe, so great
mountains. And I really love
hiking. So my perfect day would
definitely first start with a
good with a good breakfast with
eggs and bacon, you know, and
then like a nice hiking trip.
Best case would be in the
mountains, having wonderful,
sunny weather. And yeah, having
a great day outdoors.
Nice. Sounds like my perfect day
as well. All right. The stage is
yours.
Thank you very much. Yes. Yes.
So thank you for the kind
introduction. And yeah, my name
is Tomas Becker's. And yeah,
today, I want to present our
work on to second hand Gaussian
processes for turning up
electromechanical systems. And
in general, so my background is
in control theory. So I'm coming
from, like the idea of safe
learning based control. And so
essentially, we started to think
about, like, how can we make
that possible? But let me start
with the motivation. So when we
think about today's systems,
then we can we notice that
actually, the complexity is more
and more growing up in systems
you see here, two nice example
of very nice electromechanical
system. So on the left side,
there's a new humanoid robot
from Boston Dynamics. And you'll
see like complex structure and
dynamics here on the right side
bioinspired robot from Festo
with new materials and new
actuation concepts. And you can
imagine that actually, the
control of these robots of these
systems is very challenging, at
least, it's very time consuming.
And it definitely requires
expert knowledge. So we have to
come up with models of the
systems and input a controller.
And it's very, very complex.
However, I mean, you can also
see with perspective, the amount
of theoretical work and
experimental evaluations, we can
control these systems, right,
you'll see like this, how this
robot jumps, how this robot on
the right side is actuated and
can grip objects. But the
problem is that sometimes we
still say and we might say it
because we are not a big con
Consider, like all parts of the
system dynamics sufficiently
accurate. So are monitored, as
you know, are never perfect. So
there's always a mismatch
between the model of the system
and the actual system. And this
can be in control. So if you use
this model to control the
system, this can lead to some
key issues. As you can see in
the videos on the left side,
again, the Boston Dynamics
robot. And you see, at some
point, he steps on some soft
material here, right at the
moment. So and these are, these
are part in the dynamics of the
system, oh, and the environment
that we are not able to capture
in our model, because it's too
complex, because it's very
nonlinear, or just too time
consuming to model all these
things. So that means that we
have always traveled to find
good models, or that were never
able to really get a perfect
model due to too complex
dynamics in our system due to
some soft materials, for
example, or just like new
environments, like on the right
side, so maybe there's like some
wind. And so my, my drone
crashed here. What we could
experience in the last decade
that machine learning is a very
promising approach to tackle
this issue. So the idea is,
instead of using first principle
models, so using like, standard
physics like od ease, to come up
with a model of the system,
we're using data. So we collect
data of the system, and then be
using some machine learning
models. And we use these models
then for coming up with a
controller. And here you see
three examples. So the first one
is actually already quite old.
So this is a robot, which learns
how to flip pancakes with we
reinforcement learning approach.
And so you, we use the machine
learning model, to learn the
dynamics of the pancake. And you
can imagine that like these
dynamics, pretty hard to write
down just by hand. Another
example, you might know from
DeepMind, also already some
years ago, where we used to
reinforcement learning to learn
how to actuate the stickman. So
he can walk and even jump over
obstacles. And more recent
example from robotic hand from
open AI, which learns how to
actually many manipulators
Rubik's cube. And also here, you
can imagine that like a model
for the cube rubik cube is quite
hard, because you see you have
some slips, you have
uncertainties, and so very, very
complex model. But you can also
see is that actually all the
systems are not very safety
critical, right? So I mean, like
with a pancake, maybe you you
have a bad breakfast, if it's
gone a bit go wrong. But I mean,
it's not safety critical, right?
And with a stickman Rubik's
cube, so it's mostly like toy
example. And what's the reason
here? I think one of the main
reasons is that most of our
machine learning techniques so
far are mostly blackbox models,
right? So we don't really know
when they work and how good they
work. I mean, we just hope that
if we have enough data, then
they're going to be good enough.
So my actually research focus.
And so my research vision is
actually how we can establish
safe and robust control of
totally unknown or at least
partially unknown physical
system, which means that we do
not know the dynamics, we don't
have a good model of the system.
So how can we come up with a
good controller, and everything
like, getting a good controller
always, is based on having a
good model of the system? So I
think what we need is, first of
all, we should definitely
include the prior knowledge we
have about the system because
especially like electrical,
electromechanical systems, we
have a lot of prior knowledge
about it. I mean, we know there
are some physics in the
background, right? So we have
Newton's law, we have energy
conservation and all these
physics in the background. So we
should think about what we know.
And definitely include this
knowledge as prior knowledge and
our learning processes. Then we
always have a part that we do
not know these can be some
uncertainties, this can be an
electromechanical system, for
example, friction, which is
really hard to model. So these
are typically parts which are
not captured by our models, but
as in our systems, but we can't
really model it. So these are
the parts we do not know about
the actual system dynamics. And
they'll come from important
part. The important part is to
come up with safe controls, so
to get some guarantees if I can
actually control my system or
not. And that's a part of that
we need some uncertainty
quantification. So we definitely
Need to know what we don't know?
Right? So that means, if you
have a model, it's not enough to
get some predictions of this
model, we also need to know like
how certain predictions are. So
can we really trust the model? I
mean, in best case, we have a
trustworthy model. But at least
we want to know, in case if our
model is not trustworthy,
because then we can think about
strategies, how to still
guarantee the safety, but at
least we have to know if our
model is trustworthy, or when
it's not trustworthy. Okay, so,
and the outline of this talk is,
so the knowledge pipeline, what
we do in control, as I said, is
that we have our system here
from the system, we come up with
some model. And here we focus on
data driven models, and then we
use these models and control.
But today, I just wanted to talk
about this left part. So, when
we have an electromechanical
system and we collect data, how
we can come up with a data
driven model, how we can include
trial knowledge into this model.
And so, first of all, I
introduced Gaussian processes,
because the title of the talk
also includes Gaussian
processes. So, you can imagine
working here with these
processes as a machine learning
model, then the first part of
the target then I will introduce
Gaussian process port
Hamiltonian systems, which is,
which is some class of physics
enhanced data it was model we
use. And in the second part, I
will talk about a Gaussian
process variational auto
encoder. Okay, so before I dive
into Gaussian processes, let me
start again with why we want to
have physic informed learning.
So, as I said, in control, we
have like two different concepts
of how we can operate the
control. So, both concepts is
always the idea, if my control
loop, for example, I want to
control a robot, and I have to
come up with a controller,
scientifically, I start with
some model of the system. And
when I talk about the model, so,
we have normally talked about an
OD E model. Okay, so bunch of
creation of OD e equation. And
we have two different ways,
actually how to do that. So, the
first one is like physics based
and that's the way we did like
in the last 100 years, I would
say, and the right side is
learning based. Okay, let's have
it physically. So what are the
benefits of a physic based
model? Okay, so really where I
can write down the OD ease of
the system? So first of all, a
generalized well, right, I can
actually evaluate this model on
all points. So I'm not focused
on a specific area. If I have
this model, I can guarantee like
some performance and stability
properties of my close to so I
go don't go into the details. So
by then control theory, we have
a really strong math background,
how we can guarantee specific
performance if we know that the
model is correct, or at least we
know that the model is like
almost correct. So if we have
some uncertainty quantification,
then we can tell you how good
this control loop work. The
problem is always the model
selection, as I said, when we
want to model friction, for
example, friction is very
complex concept or just general
non linearity is in our system.
So what kind of model do we use?
Here, if you think about, which
is also like an interesting
topic at the moment, like human
robot collaboration, like
exoskeletons, and so on, so we
have the human in the loop? So
how can we model the human with
equations, right, so this is
pretty, pretty tough problem.
And it's also time consuming. So
if you want to get a good model
of a robot of quadcopter of
whatever kind of system, it's
really time consuming, you need
expert knowledge and a lot of
time to come up with an accurate
model. On the other hand side,
think about learning based
approaches. So, instead of
coming up with a physical model,
we collect data of our system,
and for example, in your
network, or whatever kind of
machine learning model, and we
use this machine learning model
then to come up with a
controller. And you know, we're
they these models are highly
flexible, normally, we just knew
need minimal expert knowledge.
So, we can like in the simplest
approach, we can just use a
standard neural network collect
data using some toolbox and then
we have some kind of model
right. The problem is, we do not
know how to channel as well. So
normally we assume okay, like
around my training data,
hopefully kind kind of works
well. But outside this regime, I
have no idea what happened
actually. And, like, as I said,
so these are typically blackbox
models, so we'll just get some
output, we do not know how
trustworthy this model is, we
have no uncertainty
quantification. So, in this
case, we cannot really give
stability or any performance
guarantee. And so, yeah, I've
had kind of naturally to think
about, okay, how can we bring
together the best of both
worlds? How can we bring
together like, the guarantees
from physic based model together
with the flexibility of learning
based models, and this was to me
the motivation to start looking
into physic enhance learning.
Okay, so, yeah, let me introduce
our first problem statement. So
we think here, we want to talk
to you about electromechanical
system, which can be expressed
as some type of OD function
here. And we are input if time
to see where p or the f function
saw the dynamics, and then an
input matrix G here, and an
input u. Okay. And x is the
state of the system, for
example, the position and
velocity of your mechanical
system. And then we actually
observe the system. And we
collect data, and our data
countries have to have a
timestamp. So for example, every
second, we record the state of
the system, and the state can be
corrupted by noise. That's,
that's very typically, for
example, if I have sensors on my
system, I always have some noise
in my measurements. So we assume
we can have here some Gaussian
noise, zero mean Gaussian noise
on the state measurement, okay.
And then over time, I collect
some state measurements. And
this is actually my data set.
And I also incorporate the input
to my system. For example, if I
have a motor, that will be, for
example, the torque of the motor
to the robot. And when I talk
here about electromechanical
systems, I think it's important
to mention here that these kinds
of systems are typically low
dimensional. So we talked about
like, I don't know, two to maybe
1012 states. So these are the
ticket systems we're dealing
with, but often highly
nonlinear, because we have like
these nonlinear materials or
nonlinear elements in our
system. So it's low dimensional,
but highly nonlinear. Okay, and
the problem is, now given this
data set D, we aim to find a
dynamic model of our system. But
first, we present a large class
of systems. So we want to keep
the flexibility. So we're going
to come up with a physic and
font machine learning model,
which is flexible, so which I
can use for different type of
electromechanical system. So
shall be expressive. Then, as I
said, we are in control we're
interested in and certainly
classification, because at the
end of the world, when we want
to use these models in control,
we need these uncertainty
quantification to give
guarantees about the performance
of the controller. So we're
looking for a model, which is
reliable, or at least it should
tell us if it's trustworthy or
not. And then the last point is
that it should respect physics.
So it should, and if it's
respect to physics, it
generalizes Well, right. So then
we can use the model not only
close to the training data, but
also if we have sparse training
data, or if we're in an areas
without much training data.
Okay, and yeah, now, okay, we
decided we want to do some
physical prompt learning, right?
But so what's our machine
learning model here? And yeah,
quick overview, very, very
simplified overview, I would say
about different models. And here
on the x axis, you'll see
explosivity on here, if we have
any kind of uncertainty
quantification, and first of
all, we can think about
parametric models right. So for
example, a simple linear model,
you know, you have two
parameters a and b, and you can
do like, least square and then
you have like this regression
model, it's very simple, but not
very expressive and does not
have any uncertainty
quantification. networks of
course, very expressive, can
deal with large data sets, but
at least in the plain form, we
also have no uncertainty
quantification. Then we have
like the whole part of Bayesian
parametric models, right. So,
where a and b, you put some
prior distributions on A and B,
and you can use based theory
William to get the posterior
distribution, you know, and then
you have a regression, actually
with some uncertainty
quantification. Again, same
problem. It's not very
expressive, even if you have
more complex parametric model,
but it's the like, mostly simple
model. And then we have like, we
can combine the best of both
worlds kind of, and these are
Gaussian processes. So and
Gaussian processes actually
allows us to include prior
knowledge in a very nice way.
It's a NonParametric Technique,
which means it's actually very
flexible. And it gives us
uncertainty quantification
application we want to see.
Okay, so let me talk more about
Gaussian process. Because this
is a very central point for for
this talk, we use it like and
both approaches. So the idea of
a Gaussian process is actually
that the Gaussian process is a
distribution over function
space. So you can think about
like a Gaussian distributed
variable, which is fully defined
by a mean, and a variance,
right. And now you make it
dependent over some index set,
for example, the real numbers,
so don't make it a function. And
so you have like, you can
describe a Gaussian process by a
mean function, m of x, and some
covariance function. So what's
the covariance between two
points in your input space. And
the point of the Gaussian
process is that if you, you have
now like a function or in finite
number of random variables, and
if you pick any finite set of
these random variables, it's
always jointly Gaussian
distributed. Okay, so if you
pick two, for example, two
variables, they're jointly
Gaussian distributed here.
And this means, so let's assume
we have some index here, you're
our input x and some output Y.
And in red, here, this red line
is now our mean, the gray is our
uncertainty. And now if you pick
like two variables at a random
variable, so one at location X
one, the other one at location X
two, so we have the random
variable y one and y two. So
what's now the joint
distribution, it's a Gaussian
distribution, as I said, and we
see here the mean function, and
here the covariance function
between these two points in the
input space. Okay, so any finite
set of a Gaussian process
follows a Gaussian distribution.
And now what we can do with this
Gaussian process is we can use
it for regression. And the idea
is the following. So we use the
theory, which means we start
with some prior distribution,
which can hear this to mean
distribution, then we collect
data. And based on this data, we
update the fire, and we get the
posterior, right. So that's the
idea of base theory. And that's
what we do here. So you see an
example on the right side. When
I collect data, I improve my
prediction. And what you can see
here, again, increased
uncertainty. And we have now one
data point. And what you can see
the uncertainty here around this
data point is decreasing this,
which makes sense because we
have data so our model tells us,
okay, I'm actually very certain
here about my prediction, and
these colored lines and are
sampled from the Gaussian
process. So each time proper
Gaussian process is a function
is a deterministic function. And
each function is like one
possibility, right? Based on the
data you collected, and what you
can see, if you collect more
data, your uncertainty is
decreasing, which makes sense,
right, and all the samples you
drew from the Gaussian process
coming closer and closer,
because you're most certain
about the actual underlying
function. Alright, and if you
have a lot of data, it can be
noisy data, then this
uncertainty is very small, and
you're very certain about your
output. Okay. And so if we want
to do a prediction, if we have
collected data, and we want to
do a prediction for a new test,
input x star, based on a
training set D, okay, capital X
is your, the position of your
input position of your data,
capital Y is the output position
of your data, then we get like
two, we get a very nice analytic
closed form solution here.
That's also a nice property of a
Gaussian process. So you get a
closed form solution for the
prediction. And again, since
it's, since it's Gaussian
distribution, it's fully defined
by the mean and the variance. So
what you see here is now the
posterior distribution, okay, so
the mean for the output, given a
test input, and your data set D
And what you can see on the
right side here, there's a
creation, you see the fire mean.
This and function, you see the
covariance function again, the
covariance tells you how we
related are two points in your
input space. So I have two
covariance between my test input
and my training data set capital
X, then here I have my
covariance of the training data,
sort of capital X. And here my
output data capital Y. Okay, so
you see, it's very kind of
simple function, what you get as
close from solution for the
posterior. One of the drawbacks
of Gaussian processes, you can
directly see here. And what you
see here is that you have to
compute the inverse of this
covariance matrix. Okay. And
it's inverse, the covariance
matrix, like the dimension
depends on how much data you
have. So if you have more data,
then you have to take an inverse
of a very large matrix. Okay, so
there are different approaches
how to reduce this, but yeah, I
don't want to talk about the
details. But normally, this is
some kind of drawback of a
Gaussian process. Okay, and,
yeah, to think about a Gaussian
process, we can also think from
a perspective of linear
regression. So you can think
about that you have some
training data. So you want to do
a Bayesian linear regression. So
you have a linear function, you
put a prior a Gaussian prior on
the weights on these w's, you
have some measurements of this
unknown function, again,
corrupted by some Gaussian
noise. And then as we know, I
mean, by doing some math in the
background, we can come up with
this standard expression for
Bayesian linear regression.
Right. So again, it's a normal
distribution, given our data
set, given some input point,
the, the distribution of the
output is Gaussian, defined by a
mean, and by some variance,
okay, so this standard Bayesian
linear regression, and what now
happens, but you can think about
the Gaussian process. So what we
do is, we kind of transform,
Bayesian linear regression in a
higher dimensional space. So you
can think about it. For example,
if we, it's easier to think
about it, like from the
perspective of classification.
So imagine, we want to find a
linear function to separate like
these two points, okay. And
these are the squares and these
circles. Okay, I'm not working
like in these two dimensional
space, but what we can do is, we
can lift it to a three
dimensional space, for example,
here to this sphere. And here,
we can easily find a linear
plane to separate these two
training datasets. Okay. And
that's the idea, actually, what
what you can think about is
about a Gaussian process is
doing, we're doing Bayesian
linear regression, but in a
higher dimensional space. And
this higher dimensional space is
actually timed by some feature
map. So you have some mapping
from this lower dimensional
space to this higher dimensional
space. And instead of using like
the x, the input, we just now
use this feature mapping from
the input. Okay, so we do this
transformation from the input to
the higher dimensional feature
space. And the nice thing is
here, because when you remember,
like in the in the posterior
distribution of the Gaussian
process, you didn't see this
feature map. And the point is
that we actually don't really
need to know this feature map.
Because it turns out that if you
put it like in this equation
here from Bayesian linear
regression, that always appears
as inner product. So the only
thing we need is the inner
product of the feature map. And
this is exactly the kernel
function or the EPS and so from
a Bayesian perspective, we think
about it as covariance. From a
machine learning perspective,
this is often called the kernel
function. Okay. Okay, so that
was like the quick introduction
into the Gaussian processes, and
now really the pot like how can
we incorporate phonology into
the Gaussian process? And when
we take a look on the mean
function, so this is like this,
again, the posterior mean,
expression for the Gaussian
process, it's slightly
different. It's written in a
slightly different way, but he
again I have to fire mean, and
here this part is now written as
the sum over the number of data
points he has my covariance
function and this weighting
factor depends on on the
collected data, okay. And if you
see this equation, you can
directly come up with two ways
how to incorporate training,
prior knowledge. First one is
via the meaning function, right.
So you can think about including
some parametric model s mean
function, and this would act as
some guidance right. So, without
data it will follow your main
function, but as soon as you
have data you trust like or you
rely on the data and you can
diverge from your main function
the other way is via this kernel
function or correct order or
covariance function right. So,
we can also think about how can
we design this covariance
function okay. And this is
different from the mean function
because as I said the covariance
function is connected to this
feature map like where you lift
your Bayesian linear regression
here. So, this means this
covariance function actually
defines the class of functions
of your Gaussian process. So,
let me give you here some
example. So, if you have some
training data points
a very simple covariance
function is the so called linear
covariance function and this
kernel function actually defines
the space of linear functions.
So, which means, like every
posterior mean of a Gaussian
process is always a linear
function okay. So, you limit the
class of regression. So, are you
limited the function class for
you regression to linear
function and from the machine
learning community, we got very,
we get many like different
kernel function for example, the
so called Martin Corona which
defines the smoothness of your
function so, you can say okay,
you can reduce your function
class to one time differentiable
functional two times
differentiable function and so
on. And also the squared
exponential kernel, which is a
very popular kernel regenerates,
always smooth function. So this
is a class of smooth fun. Okay,
but so far, this is like a
perspective, like a function
perspective. So, what are the
properties of your function? But
how can we now actually include
physics? Okay, so how can we
encode physics and the ideas
here that we come up with a very
general physics model? Okay, and
what we, what we chose is the
class of Polycom Etonian system.
So this is a very general
framework how to describe
physical system, especially
electromechanical system. And
I'm sure you all heard about
Hamiltonian systems. And this
Hamiltonian system is a specific
form of support Hamiltonian
system, so called Mr. Tonin
system as some kind of an
extension of Hamiltonian system.
But it's the same idea we have
some Hamiltonian function, which
is like the general energy in
your function. But now we have
some interconnection matrix and
this interconnection matrix
defines the internal flow of
your energy. For example,
thinking about the pendulum, it
would define like how the energy
flows from kinetic energy to the
potential energy in the system,
then in contrast to a
Hamiltonian system, we can also
have some dissipation in our
system, okay. And this defined
by this math matrix are, for
example, if you have friction,
it will be part of this matrix
R, then we have some input
matrix G, and some output y of
our system, important metoden
system have some very nice
properties. So J is Q symmetric
by definition. And this always
ensures energy conservation. So
at least if we have no
dissipation of zero, then we
have energy conservation, then
the energy is always constant.
The input and output defines a
passive system, we can connect
different automaton and system
and get again a port Hamiltonian
system, so we preserve the
structure. And finally, like
since it's like an energy driven
model, it's very suitable for
multi domain applications. So
it's very easy to connect
electrical system with a
mechanical system, because it's
everything is under the big
umbrella of an energy er if the
total energy of the system okay,
and our idea now was like that,
we have data from some kind of
political system, we collect
this data, and then we try to
learn such port Hamiltonian
system in connection with the
Gaussian process model. And the
idea is that we put a Gaussian
process prior on the
Hamiltonian. So we use the
Gaussian process to learn the
energy of the function. And we
also do some parameter
estimation for these matrix
matrices J, R and G. Okay, so we
assume we have no knowledge at
all about the energy of the
system, but we assume we have
some at least structure
knowledge about these matrices
J, R, and G, which are typically
kind of simple, but we can learn
parameters in these matrices.
Okay, and so we come up with the
physics and form Gaussian
process model. Since we use like
this underlying parameters and
see systems in the Gaussian
process. And what we get here is
you can think about, if we now
sample from this Gaussian
process model, it gives you some
kind of distribution about all
possible part Hamiltonian
systems under this PP prior,
okay, so you can think about,
instead of just getting one
model, you get like a
distribution about model. But
each model it says, is like
physically correct, because
there's always this underlying
pot Hamiltonian system. So we
will see an example on the next
slide. So let me explain the
pipeline here. So again, we have
our system, we collect a state
of our system over time, but the
first step is what we do, we use
some filter to come from the
time and state information to
state that derivative, okay, so
like in like other approaches,
but we actually need is like, we
need the state and the state
derivative to do the regression
with the Gaussian process. So we
can use some kind of filter, we
you see a Gaussian process, but
the at least and control, and
there are many other features
you can use, then we have our
Gaussian process to learn the
Hamiltonian, we learn we are
able to learn some parameters in
our matrices. And after the
learning process, we sample from
this Gaussian process. So for
example, we can draw 10 samples.
So we get like 10 deterministic
pot Hamiltonian systems, then
what we have to do is doing some
approximation to make it more
computationally tractable. And
then we put this in an OD
solver, and then we get
trajectories live from our 10
Centerport Hamiltonian system,
can each object we is like one
possible model, based on the
data we collected. Okay, and if
we collect more data, these
trajectories are closer
together. If we have less data,
then of course, we see more
fluctuation between these
models. Okay. I think I speed up
a little bit so that we can also
come to the second part of the
talk. So as I said, we have here
the fetus on the only purpose of
this data is that we come from
time state information or data
to state state derivative. And
what we do is simply, we use the
time and states we fit a
Gaussian process into this data.
And then we take the derivative
of a Gaussian process, since
it's a closed form solution,
it's easy to take the derivative
if you can directly take the
derivative of the covariance.
And what we get is then the mean
prediction for the state and the
mean prediction for the state
derivative. And so we can create
a new data set with the state
information again, for example,
like the position and velocity
of the robot, and derivative,
like the bullish velocity and
the acceleration, and then the
actual core of the set forward,
we put a GP prior then on the
port Hamiltonian system done.
And what we get is then a new
kernel function, okay, and this
kind of function is like
inspired or includes this port
Hamiltonian system structure.
And so we have like, a Gaussian
process for the right hand side
of our od E. And what we use
here is the property of a
Gaussian process that it's
closed under linear operator,
which means if g here is a
Gaussian process, and you have a
linear operator acting on your
on your process, then you can
include that in the process. And
f is again, it goes in process,
okay, it's the same like a
Gaussian distributed variable,
if you have a linear operator on
a Gaussian distributed variable,
like it's again, a Gaussian
distribution, right. So if X is
Gaussian distributed, A times X
is also Gaussian distributed.
And that's the same for Gaussian
processes. So for example, we
can have the differential
operator, and we can include it
in the kernel function. And then
what we could do is, for
example, if we do function
regression, but we do not have
as training data, the function
values, but the derivatives of
this function of this function
at some positions, right, we can
take the derivative and then do
a prediction of the value, of
course, plus minus some
constant. But so we can easily
combine everything with a linear
operator. And that's exactly
what we do for the pod
Hamiltonian system kronor.
Because remembering the
structure of a pod Hamiltonian
system, so everything before
this Hamiltonian function is
actually linear up Right, so we
have the derivative, we have the
multiplication with J and r. So
this is the linear operator on
the Hamiltonian. So this means
here in the center of our kernel
function, we have the squared
exponential kernel, because we
UCL squared exponential, because
we know the Hamiltonian is
actually a smooth function. And
then we use the linear operator,
which is here, the J and the R
matrix, and derivative with
respect to x. And so we can come
up with a new covariance
function, which now includes the
spot Hamiltonian structure.
Okay, and as I said, if we have
some unknown parameters in our
matrices, J, R, and so on, we
can actually treat these
parameters as hyper parameters
in the learning process. Okay,
so we can learn it. So in
Gaussian process, you use the
log likelihood function to
optimize the log likelihood
function to get the parameters
which describe best our data.
And so you can treat our
parameters, hyper parameters,
and then we come up with this
kernel function, which is
actually a distribution of a
port Hamiltonian system. Okay,
so this was the learning part.
So this is pretty nice, I think,
because it's a closed form
solution for everything, then
for the sampling after we
collected data, and we did the
learning now to get accurate
predictions from your model. So
what we do is, we now have two
sample so and the simpler way
would be to sample now from this
Gaussian process, which would
give you a deterministic
function for the right hand side
of your od E. Okay, this would
be one sample of your port
Hamiltonian, Gaussian process.
And so you could use this model,
put in an OD solver and get the
trajectory. However, this is
kind of computationally costly,
I don't go into the details, but
what we do is then instead of
getting the entire right hand
side, we learn or we sample the
Hamiltonian, okay, so we do not
get a sample from the entire
right hand side of the OD E, we
just sample a Hamiltonian, okay.
And then we use some
approximation technique for the
Hamiltonian. And then we put the
Hamiltonian again in this
quantum internal structure, and
then use an OD solver to get our
trajectory. Okay, so the
takeaway message is here, we
sample the the Hamiltonian from
our model, and we put it in the
structure, and then we have a
nice ote model. So a
deterministic model for each
sample, we can put an OD solver,
and we get a trajectory. Okay,
and for this kind of pot
Hamiltonian system, we have also
some theoretical resides. So
again, without going into the
details here, due to the time
constraints, but what we can see
is that if we draw samples, we
actually get pot Hamiltonian
system, which have all the nice
property of normal port
Hamiltonian system. Okay, I skip
your idea of the proof. But this
is similar to like the proof of
normal port Hamiltonian system.
And the other interesting
property, especially from a
learning perspective, is that it
allows now composable learning,
okay, think about like you have
a big system, like with many
different complex parts. And now
you can separate your system and
learn these parts separately.
And at the end of the day, you
can now combine your
probabilistic model with other
probabilistic models. And again,
it's one big pot Hamiltonian
system, okay, and still have
this closed form solution. So
this is this is very nice
property of this Gaussian
process. What we use here okay,
an example here. So here with
like a toy example, what we use
here is this wet ball, some
island ball, and we have here
coil, which creates a magnetic
field, and when it creates a
magnetic field, it attracts the
ball, right? And it's a nice
electromechanical system,
because you can imagine that the
inductance actually depends on
the position of the board, okay,
so like, the mechanics influence
electric and the other way
around. So what happened if the
ball roll round and return on
this inductance or this car,
visualized here by this red
color, then it attract the ball
and so yeah, that's like a nice
physical system. Okay, and here
we collect some data points, and
on the right hand side, but you
can see is now our Gaussian
process model with four samples
and this color note three
standard sorry And these colored
balls are now samples of the
Gaussian process. Okay, our port
Hamiltonian system, what you can
see here is like, we have not
just like I don't know, 2030
data points. So our models are
quite different. But the point
is that like each model is
physically correct. So from the
perspective of both Hamiltonian
systems, okay, so each model is
like, correct, in terms of the
evolution of the energy. And if
you collect more data, like in
this example, then of course,
our models are closer together,
our uncertainty is smaller, and
lighter trajectories are very
similar. Okay, so we get a nice
model with some kind of
uncertainty quantification,
because we can draw some samples
and actually see, like, what is
the variance among the samples?
And yeah, if we take a look on
the numerical results, so the
important message here is what
you can see, as I said that each
model is physically correct. And
if you take a look especially on
the Hamiltonian, so the dashed
line is the actual system. So
the real system, and the colored
lines, and our sandpit from our
Gaussian process model. And you
can see here and the red square.
So in this, at this time, we
turned, turned off the coil. So
what we want to observe here is
that the energy is only constant
or decreasing, right, because we
don't put any external energy in
this in the system. And you see
that that's true for all
samples. So and that's what I
meant by that the samples are
physically correct, okay, so the
take home message is here, even
response data, or even without
any data, I was our samples are
always like, physically correct.
And of course, if you have more
data, then your model is getting
closer and closer to the actual
system behavior. Okay, and we
have some extension, which I
just want to briefly mention. So
we extend it to a switching
system, for example, for this
hopping robot, where you have
switching dynamics in your
system. So we can come up with
switching port Hamiltonian
systems, where we use a Gaussian
process as as classifier here,
in addition to our known
Gaussian process, part
Hamiltonian system. And so we
can also identify this hopping
robot, and what we get from the
GP classifiers. Now it's takes
us in which mode we are here for
the hopping robot, people have
two modes, we have one mode,
where we are in contact with the
ground and another mode, where
are we where the robot is in the
air. And so we have two
different dynamics. And with the
GP classifier now tells us, if
we are in mode one and mode two,
and again, we can then sample
from this from this model. And
we have like the very similar
properties, as I showed you
before. Another extension is
that so far, we only had
parametric,
or we can only be only able to
estimate some parameters in our
J, r and t matrix, but this is
some kind of limitation,
because, for example, fiction
would be some nonlinear function
in your arm matrix. Okay, so
some complex function, okay, not
just like a parameter. Like,
yeah, like in a very simple
friction model, you just have, I
don't know, a parameter in front
of your velocity or something
like that. But normally, the
friction is much more complex.
So can we also like, estimate
more complex elements here and
our J and our matrix. And the
idea is here, that since we love
Gaussian processes, so much, we
also put now another Gaussian
process here and our matrices,
okay. And, again, we we have to
think about how we can guarantee
this Q symmetry, he also has a
matrix, and that is our matrix
is positive. But there are ways
to do that. Then what we get is
that we can also learn some
nonlinear friction, for example,
the only problem is that we have
since we have now here got a
Gaussian process and another
Gaussian process on the energy
wherever multiplications of
Gaussian and is not Gaussian
anymore. Okay, so in this
structure, we're losing this
nice closed form solution. And
we have to do some variational
inference to do some
approximation here to make this
problem tractable. But then we
can we can come up with a fully
Bayesian model. So when will not
only learn the energy of the
system, but also, for example,
the friction of the system. And
yet another toy example of a
pendulum, which goes here threw
some water bowl. And so we have
some friction as soon as the
pendulum is in the water, which
is like, highly non linear,
depending, of course, on the
properties of the water on the
shape, and so on. So we collect
data here on the right side to
see the phase diagram, so the
angle of the pendulum and the
angular velocity in red, you see
the actual, the real system
trajectory. And in yellow now,
the Learn system trajectory, and
the green spots are data we
collect, so we collect more and
more data. And you can see even
after like, I don't know, 3040
data points, you get already a
pretty good estimation. And
again, here, it's always
physically correct, the only
thing is how good the model is,
okay. And the color, the
background color, actually is
the uncertainty, again, here. So
the blue area says it's very
uncertain, and yellow greenish
area tells us it's more
uncertain, okay, and make sense,
because then the area was
training data are more or less
more certain. And in the area
with our training data, we have
more uncertainty. And here you
see, again, the black line is
our model like that. This is the
energy over the time. And again,
we are always like physically
correct in terms of the energy
because the energy, sorry, is
always decreasing over time.
Okay, this was the first part,
the second part, I tried to
compress it to two that we can
also talk about this. So the
first part was about potting
material system. The second part
is also again, bringing together
physics and Gaussian process,
but in a very different setting.
Because so far, we assumed we
always have state measurements,
right? So we have some sensors
on our system, for example,
position sensors, velocity
sensors, and we get the state
measurement. But what if we have
like more high dimensional
inputs, for example, video,
okay, so imagine we have a
pendulum, and you take a video.
And now we want to learn like
these dynamics. Okay. So we have
a high dimensional input. And,
yeah, the goal is to now using
videos of your system, that we
want to learn a low dimensional
latent space. And because for
example, with a pendulum, we
know we can actually we present
the dynamic libraries to states
based on these videos. And of
course, we want to again have
that these legend spaces feel
physically correct. So
respecting some prior knowledge,
and we want to have our
uncertainty quantification.
Okay, and the motivation,
motivation example is here.
Imagine that we have a car. So
we have a video of a car, for
example, going over a bumpy
road, okay. And we want to learn
a low dimensional representation
for this video frame, okay. And
we can actually express such a
visual frame by two variable,
the position, so the vertical
position of the tire and the
vertical position of the car
itself. Okay. But the thing is,
again, you have some physics in
the background, right? So there
is a coupling between the
position of the tire and the
position of the car, right?
There are some dynamics here
based on the spring and the
damper, right? And so we think
about how can we actually make
use of this prior knowledge. So
maybe we know the dynamics of
the car, right? Because we
designed the car, but what you
don't know is actually the
external excitation of the of
the wheel. Okay, so how can we
include this prior knowledge
about the dynamics about the
coupling of the wheel position,
and the car position? And so we
were thinking about, like a
Fizik, enhance variational auto
encoder to learn this low
dimensional latent space. And
yeah, variational auto encoder,
I think I don't have to talk too
much about it. I think you all
know how it works, right? We
have some high dimensional input
data, we have a network, which
compresses data to low
dimensional space. And since
it's a variational auto encoder,
not a classic auto encoder. So
we actually what we get is some
Latin distribution. So not a
single point, but the
distribution in this space. And
we sample from this
distribution. And then we have
our output decoder, and we try
to learn our train our neural
networks, so that at the end, we
can reconstruct the input
through this pipeline, right,
and then we learn this low
dimensional representation from
this high dimensional space. And
that's exactly now what we do.
But now with a Gaussian process,
so the idea is that we not only
have one picture, but we have to
video right So we have a video,
we have like a picture over
time. And we use now a Gaussian
process to describe X actually
the evolution of the object's
position over time. Okay, think
about, like, a simple example
and the car, think about a ball.
Okay, so you have video of a
ball, right. And so you can
actually represent like each
frame by an X and Y position of
the ball. Alright. So um, what
we do is, we have again, and
encoder network, which compress
like this high dimensional
picture of frame to the X and Y
position, or like an
distribution for the X and Y
position. And then we have here
now since it's evolution of a
time, right, because the ball is
flowing as it's going through
the air. So it's like an
evolution over time, we have now
a Gaussian process here, because
we have like a different
position over time. But there's
some correlation between the
position right, so there's not
like random, but so we would,
for example, here assume a
smooth trajectory, for example,
for the boy. So that's why we
can use a Gaussian process,
which actually describe the
position of the ball over time,
then we sample from the Gaussian
process, okay, and again, we use
an output decoder. And we train
this entire network so that the
output reconstruct the input.
Okay, so the kind of same idea
of an autoencoder. But now, like
with an evolution over time,
where instead of having like a
Gaussian distribution, we have,
again, like this Gaussian
process to capture this
evolution over time. Think about
the physics now, how can we
include the physics and that's
now the last step, what we do
here is when we know that, so
this movement of the ball is not
like abbotsbury, but follows
some dynamics, we know that
there might be some, or there's
some unknown excitation. But
there are some dynamics in the
background, right. So like
gravity, and like this stuff.
And now we're using these
dynamics, again, to come up with
some kind of physics inspired
kernel. And we use this kind of
function in the Gaussian
process. Okay, you can think
about that we can define a class
of possible solutions of
possible trajectories for the
ball flying through there, they
are not arbitrary. We know
they're following some physics
and be reduced the class of
possible solutions and the Latin
dynamics based on these physics.
Okay, I tried to come to an end
to stay in this one hour. But so
what we are we, the goal is to
find the lesson dynamics, okay,
so we want to find a time
series, which are the positions
of the ball here. That's why and
the dynamics should be expressed
by some linear dynamic, okay,
for example, gravity, and so on.
So we have some knowledge about
this our prior knowledge that
there are some linear dynamics
in the background, which gives
us our output, but we do not
know this unknown extra unknown
excitation of our system, you,
for example, the bumps in the
road. And what we do is, we can
write down the joint
distribution, so the joint
distribution between the video
frames, and the lepton dynamics
or the video different frames
are the display by a large back
to the bat here with like, by
white videos. And the lesson
dynamics here why. And this is
pretty much what we do with
variational auto encoders. The
interesting point is here that
you see here, the first half, we
use a Bernoulli distribution,
for modeling these pixels, the
black white pixels, and on the
right side, you see again, now
there's a Gaussian distribution
over time. And again, this key
function here is our covariance,
which is the physics enhanced
kernel function. Okay. And now
thinking about this kernel
function, it's slightly
different, or it's actually a
big difference to our physic
enhanced kernel before because
in the pot Hamiltonian
framework, we learned the right
hand side of an OD E, and then
we put it in the OD solver, here
we directly want to generate a
solution over time okay. So
because like this GP defined or
gives us the trajectory over
time, and so what we want to
learn is the trajectory of the
object over time, which means we
have some dynamics in the
background. As I said, we have
an input which is unknown to us,
comes into the game dynamics, we
get an output, and so the output
is times the position of the
object. But what we can do if
it's a linear dynamics, we can
again, write it as a linear
operator. Okay, so the linear
dynamics, you can express it
with a Greens function. And if
you use the green function with
convolution, on the input, you
get the actual trajectory over
time. So everything here is
again, a linear operator on the
input. Okay? And same idea, we
can now include this in our
kernel function. So you see
here, this k u one 2k, u n, I
couldn't function. So again, for
example, squared exponential
functions on our input. And then
we have here this linear
operator, this g function, the
green functions, and the
convolution the integral. Okay,
so now the samples of my
Gaussian process are solutions
of my dynamical systems. Okay,
so trajectories of my system.
And we did it for a simple
system. Here, we assume we have
a video of a particle, which
have some mass spring damper
dynamics in the background, and
we have some external excitation
of this particle. And so this
particle is like floating
around. So this is a video we
actually observe from the
particle. Okay, and so we
collected a bunch of videos, I
think we use the 5050 videos
from this particle. And then we
put this particle into the
variational auto encoder
pipeline, with a prior knowledge
of the dynamics of the
background, but the GP is then
able to learn this unknown
excitation of the particle. And
what you can see here are two
examples now to new input.
That's a richness. So the dark
color means here that to start,
so this particular would do like
the soaker motion. And the
light. Color means that like the
endpoint of the particular, the
end on the left side of the
input, so the original on the
right side is now the
reconstruction from the decoder
network, and in between is now
the Latin dynamics. So the
crosses are the ground truth. So
that's like the actual dynamics,
which we know here in our toy
example. But usually, it's
unknown to us, right, and the
red and blue line, and now the
predictions for my Gaussian
process, okay. And you'll see a
very nice predictions here with
the uncertainty bounds from the
Gaussian process. And what you
can see if we compare it to like
the vanilla approach, which
means you just roll a Gaussian
process on the entire system
without any prior knowledge. And
you see now the difference. So
the first row is using a
standard Gaussian process to
learn everything. So without the
prior knowledge, just using a
Gaussian process, again, the
crosses are the ground true, the
lines are now the predictions of
the Gaussian process. And we
just use training data in the
first 30 microseconds, what you
can see is that first of all,
like just using the vanilla GP,
after some training steps, the
actual prediction is not very
good. And but you see, the
uncertainty is totally
increasing, when we are in an
area with our training data,
which makes sense, right,
because like without training
data, and without prior
knowledge, we don't get a good
prediction. But in the second
world with our physical inspired
model, so we get a better
prediction with the same amount
of data. And you can see a
generalize very well in the area
without data. So in the area
after 30 microseconds. So we get
still a very nice prediction,
even though we never collected
data in this time area, right.
But since we know there's like
this prior knowledge about the
dynamics, the prediction are
much better. Okay, so let me
come to an end to to keep the
time. So the first part about of
the talk was about Gaussian
process part Hamiltonian system.
The idea is that I get to
distribute distribution about
physically correct systems. And
I can use the systems to, for
example, interconnect to other
part Hamiltonian systems, and I
keep these nice properties. And
each model is physically
correct, independent of how much
data I have. So even with less
data, it's correct, but maybe
very bad. But then I have
uncertainty and feedback, and I
know it's bad, but with more
data, I get more and more
certain, and I know that now I
think good morning at the end.
The second part was about the
physic enhanced Gaussian process
variational auto encoders here
the idea is like having a high
dimensional input like a video,
and using prior knowledge about
the dynamics of the object to
describe position over time of
this object. And using this
prior knowledge, we can improve
the prediction quality and make
it more data efficient, the
whole process. And what's
interesting, but what we haven't
done so far is like, if you
train this pipeline, you can
actually create new videos, why,
but you can change the
parameters. For example, in the
dynamic thinking about the car
example. You could change like
the stiffness of your spring, or
changing the damper. And then
you can create new videos, like
with different dynamics in the
background, I think that's very
nice. Because then you can think
about like, yeah, seeing what
happens if you if you have
different dynamics, how it looks
like, and so on, and so on. And
yeah, yeah, I listed some of the
papers, which covered these
resides, and my website, and my
email. Thank you very much.
Well, thank
you, Thomas, for the nice talk.
Oh, by the way, it is okay to go
beyond the one hour. Okay.
I still try to speed up a little
bit. So that's not going to be
too late. Introduction, sir.
Yes, yeah, pretty flexible on
that. I mean, the people can
leave, because if they have
other obligations, but I mean,
it is recorded. So we are going
to upload this video later. So
they can watch it later. Again,
so I wanted to focus on you get
to you get all the material. You
want to recover in your
presentation. So that is,
that's, that's awesome. Okay, so
let's have a q&a sessions.
Although we have many people
left, that's okay. If you have
any question, I don't see any
question in chat room. So you
can have any question, please
help me then ask questions.
Yeah, I can start. Okay. So your
modal motivation. I mean, you
start with a robotic control. So
I thought it was about the
control problem. But as I
listened to you, it's not so
much about the control. And it's
you have the data and you try to
improve the model, as you add
more data using Bayesian
processing? In some sense, it's
a you're trying to get a some
sort of surrogate model. Am I
stating?
Yeah, that's totally correct. As
I said at the beginning, it's,
it's like a two step process.
What you normally do is like,
first coming up with a good
model, and then doing the
control. And actually, yeah, I
mean, I'm also working on the
control part, just like this
talk was focused just on the
modeling part. You're totally
right. I mean, the thing, what I
tried to make clear is that as
soon as we have a model, with
uncertainty quantification, then
we can use our way now and
control pipeline. Like for
example, if you heard about MPC
control, or any other kinds of
control, if we have some
knowledge about the quality of
the model, then we can typically
get some robustness statements.
And I mean, that's also like my
other big research area, like
then what kind of statements we
can get here. But yeah,
everything starts like with with
the model, right, so yeah, maybe
at some point, I can have
another talk about their second
use and these models and control
and control. Okay, I see. That'd
be on a different clock. Yeah,
so I can see that you're really
fond of vacation process. But
but as you know, there are so
many other choices. I'm
wondering if you have compared
to give some some sort of
comparison study? Yeah, close
up, we do have the menu options.
Yes.
Yeah, I mean, I, of course, look
into other modes. But the thing
is it? I think it kind of
depends on your problem, as I
said, I mean, we are mostly
thinking about like, low
dimensional problems with mostly
sparse data. Because also like,
from my previous lab, we had
like many applications of
robotics, especially in
cooperation with the human like
human robot interaction
exoskeletons and artists cases,
where you have typically very
sparse data set because the
human don't want to spend like
hours coming up with training
data, like with these past data
set, I mean, Yeah, I don't know,
for example, I tried Bayesian
neural network or something like
that, but totally not give the
same performance with like
sparse data set, you need much,
much more data. And yeah, like
in these settings, like, for us,
it turns out that, yeah, the
Gaussian process is actually the
perfect approach for us. Because
I can like, based on the idea
that you have to prior
knowledge, right, even if it's
not physical prior knowledge
that you have, like smoothness
knowledge, or so on, that you
can come up with very good
results with sparse data. And I
don't know about like, too much
other approaches where you have
this nice combination of sparse
data of closed form expressions.
And what's the last thing? I
miss something? And yeah,
uncertainty quantification.
Okay, sounds good. Well, any
questions from audience? We have
a 13 of us.
Maybe, maybe wait for Christmas,
maybe a comment? Maybe something
to add here? I mean, I don't
want to say that the the
Gaussian process is now the holy
grail for everything right. I
totally want to just say that,
it totally depends on your
application. Right? Of course,
if you have a lot of data, you
can think about other things.
But yeah, as I said, like,
depending on our applications,
or thinking about that, it
should be like, like, yeah,
having a closed form solution,
that also very nice thing about
using these models in the
control loop, that you want to
have some real time guarantees,
and so on. So that's, yeah, many
things you have to think about,
if you want to use it in
controlled settings.
That sounds good. I have another
question about the training, how
long usually does it take to
train this promotion process?
Model?
I mean, that's the long I mean,
the training is then like, about
getting the hyper parameters,
right? It's, it's been like
optimizing the log likelihood
function. Yeah, it totally
depends on how much data you
have. As I said, like, in the
like vanilla form of a Gaussian
process, it actually skates
cubically with a number of data.
So this means like, normally,
you can nicely work with like
1000 to 3000 data points, and
then it takes like, minutes,
maybe to train it or even less.
But as soon as you have more
data than Yeah, it kind of
explodes. So then you think,
after think about either, there
are like many people who think
about how to speed up this
Gaussian process. And there are
already some solutions, how to
make that possible, or really
just using a totally different
model than I think if you have a
lot of data, then of course,
neural networks, a better
choice, I think,
well, training of the neural net
is not computationally
efficient. Is it your code is
available? Is it open source?
That's not
really yet. The state, I will
make an open open source project
we are working on that. We know
that like in machine learning,
you always have these very nice
toolboxes and everything
accessible. And I think that's
something we have to work on in
the control community, but we
are definitely working on that.
Yeah. Yeah. I hope we will get a
nice package out soon.
All right. Sounds good. But if
some research group is
interested in your model, is it
shareable?
Yeah, definitely. If you're
interested, please reach out, I
can actually send you like to
code up his toy examples and so
on. So you can definitely see
how it works and work with it.
So yeah, please feel free to
reach out to me if you have any
questions about it, or the code
or something.
All right. Sounds good. All
right. Is there any question
from audience? Well, if that
let's thank our speaker Thomas
for the wonderful talk and nice
q&a. Some sense. Well, thank
you, Thomas. It's a real
pleasure to having IBM. Yeah.
Yeah. We are good. We're going
to invite you again for a second
talk. The cultural Alright,
sounds good. Okay, let me stop
the recording.